hello and welcome to this video pas pal
seats car I don't know the right way of
pronouncing it probably not
we've got a French exchange is that
possible ok you don't want to think once
in a while it helps
ok so black is already completely lost
yeah but how do we kill him how do we
kill black you should not really you
know be content with anything less than
a clean win so if I play b3 I'm
threatening Bishop III almost made
Knight bt7 however is maybe maybe an
issue a check 1936
I may be 95 I'm not totally certain yeah
yeah if I can't kill it off completely
its to be done every since I came I
don't know if 95 was actually the best
move maybe not but it is it is pretty
okay anyway so um here black I should
probably go c6 Bishop d3 that doesn't
look like a very exciting choice but
it's actually a really good move because
it speeds up White's development yeah
after this I already have two pieces in
play while black has none and this
doesn't seem like much but this is an
idea and black has to in some way
reacted to it which we didn't do and I
just didn't do it
um I analyzed c6 in my repertoire of c6
and now the important most we need to
check and black has to somehow obstruct
his position if he go Bishop e7 castles
might f6 rook e1 black is not managing
to castle that's just annoying very
annoying actually and this is yeah never
developing in the Kings side and again
squeegee is 7 I play here and castles
rook e1 next and then again the King
sighs clocked up so this is the idea
behind Bishop d3 96
yeah I'm grabbing the pawn it's just not
going to avoid that and here white is
just a lot better I mean night before I
can cancel black cannot do this yes the
night going away
yeah Queen d7 however I can
and that's totally devastating yeah 95
is the strongest move it seems I was
thinking here but night bg7 I wasn't so
sure about King e6 it looks weird but
yeah I don't have a move the Queen is
trapped
yeah but 95 is better so if he takes on
c2 I wanted to play Knight c3 years
yeah Knight c3 and now black cannot move
anything and I'm going to castle play
rook e1 and there is also the simple
threat of winning the rook which is
tough to meet and here after 95 he
actually already resigned yeah nothing
to do if you go like here I go Queen b7
and the rook is gone
yeah playing there was to quickly play
to her black hand people tend to
underestimate the exchange it's really
my experience thanks a lot for watching